walking through the city of Havana one
day I looked up and wonder all this
young time was solved I realized that
should just do something with it I do
see the future of the beauty of the city
related with the past and that pass was
the New York
you
[Music]
Cuban artists Kadir Lopez in the FS is
bringing new light and life to the
streets of Havana by restoring the
city's neon signs one by one with his
project Havana light many of these signs
have sat abandoned for decades in the
50s and 40s there was the Renaissance of
the neon in Cuba thousands of neon all
over the city of Havana the neon was
part of the architecture but in the
1960s the neon signs became difficult
and expensive to maintain and slowly
they were taken down or shut off and
left to decay
[Music]
[Applause]
today the neon is considered like a
piece of art on himself
the mission is taking the art off side
people walking in the street they don't
have to be into the museum to to look
into a piece of art over the past three
years
Kadir and his team have restored a
dozens of signs across the city it can
be a painstaking process it's not
different than fixing an old car you
take all the elements out and you start
fixing everything the roster damaged
the most difficult thing is demanded
it's a skill that very few people have
in the world so the most complicated
process is taking it down and lifting it
up because you need a lot of man's
certain places like Ohana you got to do
it by ear all by hand because big cars
and create they cannot get in there
it is phenomenal to see the people's
reaction some cases we see kind of tears
in their eyes they get so excited about
see something that was about to
disappear coming back to life
neon means restoration of hope make
people's life happier there's nothing
stronger than that
[Music]
you